ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba let's learn
the three beat weave which is a great
example of a move where if you have the
lead ups it'll come if the lead ups are
still sketchy it'll be tough so I
recommend going back and making sure you
have to lead ups if you don't let's
check face me go forward split time and
you need it balanced what we're going to
beat weaves in each side from split time
reporter and split time you can draw up
past your right foot right crosses over
and you can loop that and that needs to
feel comfortable like no big thing now
back to split time you can also drop
past your left foot swish swish and left
crosses over and you can loop that and
notice how if you're standing stiff like
this that won't work very well you need
to be like your hands are kind of in
front of you and you're bobbing and
weaving a little bit so if you can do
that both ways and they're equally
comfortable check you know you've got
one of the lead ups and you're ready to
proceed
the next lead up is this thing where you
have your arms crossed and then look you
look to your right shoulder
swing back along the wheel plane and
cross not like this is that's a wall
plane so you're going along a wheel
plane cross finish from circle left ploy
drops back crosses over right pie drops
back crosses over cross over
so for crossover if that's working
awesome you're also ready to proceed I
should face this way at first take your
right poi and you're gonna go over in
back over and back over and under and
back over and back over and back
over and under and it's that transition
that's important over and back over and
back over and under and then your left
hands here it's going to cross over
so we're gonna do that with the POI
you're gonna start at your right side to
your right it's crossing over and back
and you can say to yourself over and
back over and back over and under and if
you want just crash I try to make sure
you go to the over and under over and
back over and back over and under crash
you can go several times it's okay over
and back and what you'll notice over and
under when you go under that left boys
kind of flying through the air after
fuel truck a few tries you'll see how
you can cross that left boy over and
back over and back over and under and
play oh and then you're just doing the
left on top that's why it's so important
have these balanced because now you're
in the other to beat weave with the left
on top and the left boys going over and
back over and back over and under and
then after some crash you'll see how the
right poi will cross let's switch this
way so the sun's on my face so you can
keep alternating starting with the left
and start them with the right so let's
face this way let's start with the left
on top which means it's gonna come past
the left foot left on top left on top
over and back over and back over and
under and again you can crash ten times
in a row and if you relax with crashing
you'll start to see what's happening
over and back over and back over and
they say oh I just cross it over and I
look it's the right on top over and back
over and back over and under at left on
top over and back over and out
right on top right on top over and under
left on top left on top over and under
right and tough right on top under left
on top let them tap under right on top
under left on top under right on top
under over and under over and under over
and under over now you can't count all
the overs and unders because they're
overlapping so in the end it just feels
like right over and left over and the
way I guarantee you'll get there as long
as you're to beat leads are equally
comfortable you know the left on top
and back and you can do the right and
top and back just keep alternating which
one you're starting with so right on top
and under hoop and then you're letting
your off and then you do a little left
on top and under uh-huh
and then what this is one of those moves
where people would get it where they're
going yeah and sometimes they won't
believe they've got it they'll be doing
the whole Alice here you've got it no
see no no but not the I'll say yeah and
they'll say are you sure and I'll say
I'm sure that's the three beat we've but
the full three beat we've I was at yes
that's the full three beat we've and
then after a while they'll be like oh
because you got once you do it for a
while but eventually makes sense in your
list oh it is a three beat we've I am
doing it and you are but if you haven't
practiced the lead-ups enough it's it's
less likely to succeed so we're gonna
keep coming back to how to beautify and
mastering it really comfortable with
this next week we're going to learn the
backward three beat we've the week after
that we're gonna learn to turn in the
week I'm calling them weeks but they're
sections you can take a month with
intersection and then we're gonna add
windmill and combine them all together
and all that good stuff between so
you're doing great
as usual I I love it when you send
feedback so if you get stuck anywhere
I'll just ask you a question or send a
video of what's going on if you send a
video you're having trouble with the
final three we've make sure to show me
the lead ups what's going on the lead
ups because that's where I'll see
whether you've got them right or not and
then I'll know what the same so I
guarantee I will coach you through this
because you can all get it
what maybe you already are
[Music]